What? You think 'cause I went
to rehab, I stayed clean?
I mean, ain't that the point?
♪ (CONTEMPLATIVE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Yeah, well,
the world's coming to an end
and I haven't even
graduated high school yet.
I'm Dr. Ali Mattu,
cognitive behavioral therapist,
and I'm here today
in collaboration with HBO
to offer my take on themes
of mental health in their shows.
(SLURRED) I'm just so happy.
Today, we'll talk
about substance use
and how it can affect behavior
through the lens of Rue
in Euphoria.
RUE BENNETT: If I could be
a different person,
I promise you, I would.
Euphoria is one of the most
honest representations
of substance use problems
I've seen.
Rue talks about her history
with grief,
with a learning disability
and anxiety.
RUE: All of a sudden,
I couldn't breathe.
They gave me liquid Valium.
And I found a way to live.
Some people might be vulnerable
to developing problems
with substances,
because they're experiencing
underlying mental illness.
FEZCO: I don't know
what type of fucked up shit
you got going inside your head.
And I don't know how to help.
But I could tell you
one thing...
This drug shit
is not the answer.
The stereotype that exists
in our country
is certain people are addicts
and will always be addicts.
And that's just not true.
As we treat the underlying
mental illness,
substance use can often
resolve itself.
This is something we can all do.
Have compassion,
and in a judgment-free way...
This seems like a radical idea.
You'd be surprised at how
most people never get asked
this question.
And it opens the door.
It makes it easier for them
to talk about
what the substances are doing
and also,
get them to be open to talking
about change.
That's all I have for you today.
And remember,
if you need help,
there are resources available
to you.
I'm Dr. Ali Mattu,
and I'll see you
in the next video.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪